now thank you so much for joining us  here at noon i'm heather mills a  neighborhood on edge after a four hour  long standoff with metro finally ended  now one man is dead it started early  this morning near silverado ranch in  maryland parkway shutting down traffic  nearby witnesses say they heard fighting  between a man and woman inside of a home  a neighbor describes what she saw  i woke up to gunshots i seen him shoot i  seen guns shooting at my roof there's a  hole  above his roof where he shot  and then they came and told us to  evacuate our house  watts and crisis negotiators were at the  scene trying to get the man to surrender  but police say he ultimately died from a  self-inflicted gunshot wound